beim klimagipfel in madrid präsentiert
sich deutschland als vorbild doch
umweltschützer sehen das anders
gemeinsame linie im kampf gegen das
rauchen die große koalition will die
tabakwerbung schrittweise verbieten
friedensstifter und weltliteraten tube
ins ministerpräsident ahmed nimmt den
friedensnobelpreis entgegen der
umstrittene österreicher peter handke
den für literatur
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster reden abend bekommen bei
heute den sport hat diesmal ein
arbeitnehmer und dabei ein stück von mir
der klimawandel schreitet voran doch
bisher ist nicht viel passiert um die
erderwärmung zu stoppen wie sie
wenigstens verlangsamt werden könnte
darüber verhandeln derzeit wieder die
zuständigen minister auf der
un-klimakonferenz in madrid der gerade
veröffentlichte klimaschutz index zeigt
wo die einzelnen länder beim klimaschutz
stehen und da kommt deutschland gerade
mal auf platz 23
gemessen wurden diese vier kriterien der
ausstoß von treibhausgasen der einsatz
von erneuerbaren energien der
energieverbrauch gesamt und die
klimapolitischen maßnahmen gerade beim
letzten punkt schneiden die
skandinavischen länder besonders gut ab
was deutschland künftig besser machen
will
volker andreß vor allem der
verkehrssektor muss sich wandeln
seit 1990 sind hier die emissionen nicht
gesunken immer mehr autos fressen
einzelne motorische verbesserungen auf
und auch der kohle ausstieg kommt zu
langsam so jedenfalls sehen es die
klimaschutz kritiker auf der
klimakonferenz zeigt sich die
bundesumweltministerin svenja schulze
heute überzeugt vom deutschen
klimaschutzpaket dieses programm wird
sicherstellen wie erreichen unsere
klimaschutzziele bis 2030 also 55
prozent weniger emissionen bezogen auf
das bringt deutschland auf kurs um 2050
klimaneutral zu sein
der klimaschutz index andere länder
schneiden derzeit besser ab am
engagiertesten und damit grün markiert
ist schweden gefolgt von dänemark und
marokko dort liefert ein großes
solarkraftwerk klimafreundlichen strom
und es gibt eine nachhaltige
energiepolitik ein musterbeispiel für
viele sonnen länder die usa sind das
schlusslicht präsident trump hält nichts
vom klimaschutz
doch viele us-bundesstaaten sehen das
anders
der mögliche präsidentschaftskandidat
der demokraten mike bloomberg war heute
in madrid 400 saubere energie und eine
klimaneutrale industrie forscher
bescheinigen wie gegen geld ab wir
bekommen die emissionen um 37 prozent
runter bis 2030
ebenfalls gut aufgenommen 30 millionen
euro mehr aus deutschland gibt es für
den klima anpassungsfonds zugunsten der
entwicklungsländer
auch das kündigte die
bundesumweltministerin heute an den
kompletten klimaschutz-index haben wir
online für sie
wer steht oben und welche länder haben
noch nachholbedarf
zu finden auf heute.de ein kleiner
hoffnungsschimmer gestern in paris nach
dem ost ukraine gipfel gibt es wieder
bewegung im festgefahrenen
friedensprozess der russische präsident
putin und sein ukrainischer kollege
selensky einigten sich unter
deutsch-französischer vermittlung auf
folgende punkte im osten der ukraine
sollen bis ende des jahres die waffen
schweigen und gefangene ausgetauscht
werden
außerdem ist ein teilweiser
truppenrückzug bis märz geplant
kanzlerin merkel und russlands präsident
putin sprachen auch über einen fall der
die beziehungen beider länder schwer
belastet es geht um den mord an einem
georgier in berlin
hier hatte der generalbundesanwalt die
ermittlungen übernommen denn es gibt
hinweise dass staatliche russische
stellen in die tat verwickelt sein
könnten
putin äußerte sich jetzt erstmals zu den
vorwürfen und nahm das opfer ins visier
daniel pontzen mit mehr es waren diese
worte die viele als wendepunkt sehen von
russlands bisherige wir wissen von
nichts und wo sind die beweise haltung
hin zu offensiver vorwärtsverteidigung
mit blick auf den getöteten georgiritt
dieser mann wurde von uns gesucht der
ist ein bandit ein brutaler und
blutrünstiger man die russische seite
hatte mehrmals darum gebeten diesen
bewaffneten verbrecher diesen mörder
auszuliefern
leider haben wir keine übereinkunft
erreicht unabhängig davon dass es eine
solche auslieferungs bitte laut
deutschen regierungskreisen nie gegeben
habe
reagierten im politischen berlin viele
alarmiert bis erschrocken auf putins
aussage nachdem der georgier hier in
aller öffentlichkeit getötet worden war
womöglich von diesem nun inhaftierten
man womöglich so der anfangsverdacht des
generalbundesanwalts im auftrag
staatliche russische stellen das
statement von putin wirkt ja fast wie
ein quasi indirektes schuldeingeständnis
meiner ansicht nach ist es der bewusste
versuch allen kritikern des regimes
putin in russland wie im ausland zu
zeigen
ihr dürft euch nicht sicher fühlen wir
leugnen nicht mal dass wir was damit zu
tun haben könnten
das ist ein politisch motivierter satz
und er ist nicht akzeptabel
weniger konfrontativ die reaktion der
kanzlerin letzten acht sichtlich um
deeskalation bemüht
es gebe einen anfangsverdacht nicht mehr
und nicht weniger
das ist wohl das was ich auch dem
russischen präsidenten gesagt habe und
ich gehe davon aus dass die russische
seite ihre informationen und zur
verfügung stellt jedenfalls kenne ich
das gut putin stellte das in aussicht
kündigte jedoch zugleich nach der
ausweisung zwei russische diplomaten aus
berlin das selber als vergeltung an
einer vertrauensvoller zusammenarbeit
bringt das kaum in den usa nimmt das
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump formen an
dafür braucht es konkrete anklagepunkte
und genau die haben die oppositionellen
demokraten jetzt genannt erstens
amtsmissbrauch weil trump die ukraine zu
ermittlungen gegen seinen rivalen beiden
gedrängt haben soll
zweitens eine beispiellose behinderung
des kongresses bei den ermittlungen zur
affäre eine amtsenthebung trumps gilt
aber nach wie vor als höchst
unwahrscheinlich weil seine republikaner
im senat die mehrheit haben
finanzminister scholz nimmt einen neuen
anlauf für eine europäische
finanztransaktionssteuer
seit 2011 diskutiert die eu darüber
bisher immer ohne ergebnis im entwurf
ist
eine steuer auf aktienkäufe vorgesehen
scholz steht unter besonderem druck denn
die mittel aus der neuen abgabe sollen
in die grundrente fließen so hatte es
die koalition verabredet und die
grundrente ist er eines der
aushängeschilder der spd florian a
er macht einfach weiter heute mittag der
finanzminister und nun doch nicht
spd-chef im arbeitsmodus als hätte es
die parteiinternen niederlage nicht
gegeben
sie sehen dass ich freude haben da
arbeite ich mache ja so eine freude
heute speist sich aus einer idee die
schon jahre gestritten wird nun legt
scholz sondern europäischen partnern
einen vorschlag vor wie diese
finanztransaktionssteuer aussehen soll
die aktien großer unternehmen kauft soll
künftig so der plan eine steuer von 0,2
prozent entrichten gelten soll das nur
für aktien von grossen unternehmen
börsenwert über eine milliarde euro
kritiker bemängeln was alles nicht von
der steuer betroffen wäre
riskantere geschäfte wie sogenannte
derivate an die steuer ist nicht
geeignet spekulation zurück zu drängen
weil beispielsweise derivate gar nicht
drin sind 90 der finanztransaktionen
während davon gar nicht erfasst das
heißt diese pläne reichen in jedem fall
nicht aus scholz verteidigt den
vorschlag als kompromiss
wer in europa demokratie gut findet muss
sich schon mit anderen verständigen
wollen und das ist das was sich gezeigt
hat möglich ist doch auch der
koalitionspartner gibt sich skeptisch
bei der union fürchtet man die neue
steuer verhindere womöglich dass mehr
menschen fürs alter mit aktien vorsorgen
wir wollen dass menschen die privat für
alterversorgung gestärkt werden und
nicht durch eine börsenumsatzsteuer
belastet werden der finanzminister aber
rechnet bereits fest mit den einnahmen
1,5 milliarden euro pro jahr
geld mit dem die grundrente bezahlt
werden soll ein vermutlich noch
wichtigeres anliegen für die spd soll es
flächendeckende fahrverbote für diesel
autos in frankfurt am main geben heute
dazu eine gerichtsentscheidung in
zweiter instanz und diebe sagt nein
gleichzeitig aber legten die richter
fest dass die stadt prüfen muss welche
wirkung
innere fahrverbotszonen hätten die
bisherigen maßnahmen für bessere luft
reichen nämlich nicht bis ende nächsten
jahres sollen die verantwortlichen einen
effektiven luftreinhalteplan vorlegen
ein anderes verbot dagegen wird wohl
kommen und zwar für tabakwerbung möglich
macht dies ein umdenken in der union
bisher darf in deutschland noch auf
litfaßsäulen an haltestellen oder im
kino für tabak geworben werden
doch damit steht deutschland alleine da
in allen anderen eu ländern ist dies
längst verboten
weniger über das ende eines jahrelangen
streits nicht sofort aber in zwei jahren
soll mit dieser tabakwerbung wird fasst
sollen oder bushaltestellen schluss sein
lange hatte die union sich gegen ein
solches werbeverbot gewährt es geht um
eine grundsätzliche abwägung zwischen
freiheit auf der einen seite und schutz
auf der anderen seite
es gab bei uns auch abgeordnete die
sagten das ist ein weitgehender eingriff
den wir in dieser form nicht mittragen
wollen denn am ende ist es ja eine
entscheidung von menschen für ein
legales produkt die kritiker unterlagen
heute den verbraucherschützern in der
union ab 2021 soll tabak werbung im kino
bei film für jugendliche unter 18 jahren
verboten werden
ein jahr später soll ein verbot der
plakatwerbung bei klassischen
tabakprodukten folgen 20 24 dann ein
verbot der werbung für zigaretten
die spd hatte schon lange für solche
maßnahmen plädieren sind was
gesundheitsschädliches was enorme
volkswirtschaftliche kosten verursacht
wenn das nicht mehr beworben wird dann
glaube ich ist das eine
gesellschaftspolitische entscheidung die
dringend notwendig ist zustimmung kommt
von ärzten kritik aus fdp und industrie
der beschluss sei ein eingriff in die
werbefreiheit es insbesondere auch
kritisch weil er gesundheitspolitische
ein rückschritt ein rückschritt
darstellt denn es wird mit dieser
regulierung auch künftig nicht mehr
möglich sein über risiko reduzierte
produkte zu informieren wie
beispielsweise e zigaretten
ein gesetz steht noch aus deutschland
ist damit das letzte land in der eu das
tabakwerbung vermietet in tschechien hat
ein mann offenbar wahllos sechs
patienten im wartezimmer einer uni
klinik erschossen
anschließend nahm sich der 42 jährige
auf der flucht das leben berichtete die
polizei die hintergründe der tat in der
stadt ostrava sind noch unklar
nach angaben der regierung wurde der
tatverdächtige selbst in dem krankenhaus
behandelt er sei vorbestraft
in neuseeland geht die polizei nach dem
vulkanausbruch der frage nach wie es zu
dem unglück kommen konnte
auffallend waren gestern mindestens
sechs menschen getötet worden
31 erlitten zum teil schwere
verletzungen
darunter sollen auch vier deutsche sein
es gibt kaum hoffnung dass die acht
vermissten noch am leben sind
der vulkan war trotz verstärkter
aktivität noch ziel von ausflugsbooten
heute werden die nobelpreise übergeben
in den naturwissenschaften für literatur
und als wohl bekannteste auszeichnung
der friedensnobelpreis äthiopiens
ministerpräsident ahmed nahm ihn in oslo
entgegen
der 43-jährige habe entscheidend zum
friedensschluss mit eritrea beigetragen
und in äthiopien demokratische reformen
eingeleitet so das komitee habe bedankte
sich frieden sei harte arbeit aber eine
herzensangelegenheit
gleich zwei menschen erhielten dieses
jahr den literaturnobelpreis
nachträglich für 2018
die polin olga tokarczuk und für 2009/10
der österreicher peter handke genau das
aber ist hochumstritten
denn so sehr seine literatur geschätzt
wird so sehr steht seine haltung zum
jugoslawienkrieg in der kritik hunt
gehörte sich mit serbien solidarisiert
und den völkermord von srebrenica
relativiert hannah hebestreit über eine
auszeichnung die aufregung auslöst und
empörung
als könig karl der 16 gustav peter
handke den literatur-nobelpreis
überreicht gibt es im stockholmer
konzerthaus den gleichen höflichen
beifall wie für alle übrigen preisträger
[Applaus]
draußen aber ist die kritik groß sagt
kommunales wurde 1992 von serbischen
milizen verschleppt saß in einem
gefangenenlager jetzt protestiert er
gegen die auszeichnung für einen autoren
der damals der serbischen führung nahe
stand es geht mir nicht nur um ihn
persönlich und es gab immer leute die
die geschichte nicht andres und
falschinformationen über derart
verbreitet haben ich finde das nobel-
komitee verleiht den besten preis in der
welt an jemand könne schlicht nicht
verdient kritiker werfen handke vor
während der kriege auf dem balkan partei
ergriffen zu haben für serbien auf eine
reise durch bosnien 1996 badete er in
dem fluss in dem kurz zuvor noch leichen
massakrierte bosnier trieben und schwieg
zu den gräueltaten serbischer verbände
im umfeld der preisverleihung kanzelte
fragen danach ab
ich sage ihnen ich ziehe toiletten haben
wir dass mir irgendjemand anonym
geschickt hat sollich lehrern und
ignoranten fragen vor
saukomisch erwartet gemeinsam mit
hunderten demonstranten von peter handke
am tag der nobelpreisverleihung
wenigstens eine entschuldigung gegenüber
den opfern des schreckens auf dem balkan
die sänger des schwedischen popduos
roxette ist tot
marie fredriksson starb im alter von 61
jahren an den folgen einer
krebserkrankung
1989 schaffte sie den durchbruch mit
velux
danach feierte das duo zahlreiche
internationale erfolge 2016 zog sich
fredriksson wegen ihrer erkrankung aus
dem musikgeschäft zurück
ja und nun zum sport zur
fußball-champions-league und zu gehen
da geht es heute für den bvb um den
einzug ins achtelfinale
die devise heißt punkten und hoffen denn
ein sieg gegen slavia prag der allein
reicht nicht dortmund braucht
schützenhilfe vom fc barcelona der bei
inter mailand spielt heimspiel in
dortmund und irgendwie auch ein
auswärtsspiel in san siro
die niederlagen der vergangenheit holen
den bvb ein
es ist dann nicht mehr nur von uns
abhängig wie das ausgeht
abhängig von barcelonas gnaden denn in
mailand darf inter gegen barca nicht
gewinnen sonst wäre dortmund raus der
nebel in san siro lichtet sich und es
kommt wie befürchtet mit einer b-elf
wird barcelona antreten ohne messi und
sechs andere stammspieler für dortmund
bedeutete das ein auge in mailand mit
dem herzen zu hause gegen prag die
jüngere vergangenheit macht hoffnung
zwei siege in folge zuletzt das 15 0
gegen düsseldorf
auch ohne den nach dem treppensturz
verletzten belgier witzel ist dortmund
heute großer favorit für deutschlands
handball frauen geht es morgen im
letzten wm hauptrundenspiel um den
einzug ins halbfinale
nach der knappen niederlage gegen
serbien hat die dhb auswahl gegen
norwegen aber alles in der eigenen hand
das letzte abendbuffet vor dem
hauptrunden showdown den nachschlag soll
es dann morgen geben ein sieg gegen
norwegen wie bei der vergangenen em und
das team wäre im halbfinale
es kam gestern schon mal auf dass wir
die letztes jahr schon geschlagen haben
und warum nicht noch mal wir haben uns
nochmal weiter entwickelt sind schritte
nach vorne gegangen
wie beim erfolg gegen die starken
niederländerinnen da zeigten sie ihr
großes potenzial
gestern beim 28 29 gegen serbien nicht
da kam der heutige regenerationstag zur
rechten zeit
wir hatten jetzt in zehn tagen sieben
spiele und es zählt wirklich an den
kräften und einer konzentration auf dem
spiel
die uns ein bisschen gefehlt hat im
letzten spiel aber heute hatten wir in
freien tag und den haben wir wirklich
genutzt
doch es wurde auch gearbeitet
videoanalyse und jetzt ist der
erfolgshunger hoffentlich zurück
das wasser schon vor dem ja auch ja
danke norbert zum wetter regen und
schnee ziehen morgen über deutschland wo
sie was erwartet das zeigt ihn gleich
gunther tiersch das war es von uns danke
für ihr interesse
marietta slomka freut sich um drei
viertel 10 auf sie und wir sind morgen
wieder zur stelle um 19 uhr einen
gemütlichen abend für sie bis dann bis
morgen
[Musik]
group live zuschauer nass kalt wird es
morgen teilweise mit schnee und glatteis
regen wir haben ja ein gewaltiges
orkantief mit seinem zentrum hierbei
island und das hat eben auch eine
regenfront die jetzt langsam deutschland
überqueren wird bis morgen abend und
dahinter kommt kühle luft deshalb morgen
in den mittelgebirgen im süden ein
bisschen schnee ist auf jeden fall dabei
heute nach der regen der auf zieht dazu
wird es stürmisch vor einigen
norddeutschland schwere sturmböen aus
süden an der nordsee und es kann glatt
werden
der regen könnte auf den gefrorenen
boden fallen vor allem in der mitte
deutschlands da erwarten die
temperaturen von null bis minus ein grad
am alpenrand -10 und frostfrei bleibt es
im nordwesten morgen dann haben wir dann
meist im norden 3 bis 8 grad im süden
aber teilweise nur 0 bis 3 grad
ja es würde einen vormittag mit regen im
westen und norden schneefallgrenze bei
600 meter sonst ist es freundlich und
nachmittags zieht das ganze noch ein
bisschen nach südosten schneefallgrenze
sinkt zwischen dem sauerland und
oberfranken aber auch im schwarzwald und
auf der schwäbischen alb kann schneien
ja die aussichten donnerstag dann immer
noch ein paar schauer freitag wird's
nass mit schnee und regen dazu windig
und samstag kommt zu diesem nasskalten
wetter dann wieder ein neuer sturm
ich wünsche noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie es gut